[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos amigas el crono virus nos tiene
en vilo nos tiene preocupados a todos
precisamente por eso en esta ocasión
queremos contaros como un país está
venciendo precisamente al coronavirus
ahora que el sars coronavirus 2 ha
comenzado a extenderse ampliamente por
europa y también por américa el
sentimiento de alarma se ha multiplicado
más rápido los panes y los peces
a la hora de preparar este vídeo este
coronavirus ya ha contagiado a más de
120 mil personas en todo el mundo
todas ellas algo más de 80 mil fueron
casos confirmados en china sin embargo
los focos de contagios ya no se
encuentran en el gran gigante asiático
sino repartidos a lo largo y ancho del
mundo italia españa irán francia o eeuu
son tan sólo algunos ejemplos de una
larga lista que cada vez aglutina más
países y lugares
probablemente en poco tiempo los
contagiados en el resto del mundo
superen ampliamente los casos
confirmados hasta ahora en china con
todo lo más chocante lo más sorprendente
de esta crisis es cómo ha sido abordada
en los diferentes países
en occidente por ejemplo al principio
cuando toda esta historia solo afectaba
china se decía que estábamos ante poco
menos que un virus asesino luego cuando
empezaron a registrarse casos en el
resto del mundo de repente se convirtió
en una simple gripe y finalmente tras
propagarse el número de contagios
observar el ejemplo de italia y ver que
la gente desarrollaba síntomas muy
serios y que muchos de los pacientes
requerían hospitalización y que los
hospitales empezaban a colapsar entonces
volvió a convertirse en un peligroso
virus capaz de poner en jaque a los
diferentes sistemas sanitarios y todo
ello por no hablar del potencial daño
económico
de la noche a la mañana la amenaza pasó
a ser real e inminente el problema es
que durante mucho tiempo no se tomó
prácticamente ninguna medida y el caso
tal vez más paradigmático de esto que
contamos es el de españa mientras los
contagios se contaban ya por cientos se
seguían celebrando manifestaciones y
actos políticos y deportivos
multitudinarios
no lo recomiendo
expresar sus ideas considere y que sin
considerar que tiene
sí
no lo sé
en el caso de china fue todo lo
contrario el gobierno chino puso en
marcha muy pronto medidas radicales para
frenar la epidemia principalmente
decretaron un aislamiento y una
cuarentena prácticamente absoluta en
toda la provincia de jove y la provincia
de la que usan es la capital como todos
sabéis presumiblemente jan fue el origen
de la epidemia pues bien el caso es que
todas las medidas tomadas por el
gobierno chino fueron tachadas por
muchos medios occidentales como
exageradas alarmistas incluso medievales
sin embargo parece que ya podemos decir
que han sido todo un éxito aparente en
el momento de preparar este vídeo china
ya apenas reportan nuevos casos
positivos fijaos coronavirus china dice
que la enfermedad fue frenada en buján y
juve y si parece que china ha conseguido
vencer al virus pero la pregunta que
muchos se hacen es a qué precio
el gobierno chino no solo encerró en sus
casas a 60 millones de personas bajo la
amenaza de fuertes multas sino que
también para buena parte de todo su
tejido económico y productivo fábricas
centros comerciales bancos de todo
un momento pensaréis que exagero pues
por si acaso fijaos por ejemplo en el
índice pm un indicador que se basa en
los pedidos que las empresas hacen a
proveedores y que se utiliza para medir
precisamente la situación de la
actividad económica de un país por
debajo de 50 este índice indica recesión
pues bien en el caso de la industria
china el pmi de febrero fue de 35,7 es
decir un nivel mucho más bajo de 50 y
para que os hagáis una idea el menor
nivel desde que existe este indicador
estamos hablando de cifras más bajas que
las de los peores momentos de la crisis
del 2008
[Música]
y en el caso de los servicios no ha sido
mejor china prácticamente paró su tejido
productivo y la pregunta que muchos nos
hacemos es estarán los gobiernos
occidentales dispuestos a llegar a tanto
y ojo porque hablamos de que se podría
desatar una crisis enorme
acaso no hay otra forma de enfrentarse a
este coronavirus pues queridos amigos y
amigas de visual político justo aquí es
donde aparecen diferentes posibilidades
pero hay una que estamos convencidos de
que os va a sorprender atentos
[Música]
en tiempo y forma
sintetizando resumiendo solo hay tres
formas de enfrentarse al coronavirus
la primera empezar por no hacer nada
luego prácticamente nada para el final
hacerlo todo demasiado tarde es
básicamente la estrategia por la que
parecen han apostado países como españa
o eeuu deberes
[Música]
la segunda posibilidad es la de china
encerrar a la población y paralizar todo
un país darle al botón de stop y la
tercera tratar de alcanzar un punto
medio entre ambas posibilidades punto
medio que sea eficaz claro
sabemos que elegir entre ellas nos
resulta nada fácil por eso en este vídeo
queremos hablaros de un país que ha
tomado este tercer camino y que todo
apunta de momento a que está teniendo un
enorme éxito
hablamos de corea del sur
[Música]
amigos fijaos un momento en este gráfico
después de confirmar durante varias
jornadas casi 1000 nuevos contagios por
día
al poco tiempo la cifra ha caído a poco
más de 100
de esta forma muy pronto las
recuperaciones podrían ser superiores a
los nuevos contagios lo que implicaría
que la cumbre epidémica es decir el
número de casos totales activos
comenzaría a decrecer
[Música]
en otras palabras en el momento de
realizar este vídeo todo apunta a que se
estaría ganando la guerra contra el
coronavirus todo esto claro si las cosas
siguen bajo control ya sabéis que con
estas cosas hay que ser siempre muy
prudentes porque uno nunca sabe cuándo
puede surgir un nuevo brote problemático
pero ahora bien con los datos en la mano
la pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es
cómo ha conseguido corea del sur tan
buenos resultados en cuestión de días
corea del sur es un país que está
geográfica y socialmente muy
interconectado con china por ejemplo
cada día tiene decenas de vuelos diarios
con el país de origen de la epidemia por
eso mismo estableció medidas
extraordinarias en los aeropuertos nada
más confirmarse la epidemia el gobierno
fijó puertas de embarque y vías de
llegadas separadas para los pasajeros
procedentes de china e inmediatamente
prohibió todos los vuelos con origen o
destino en la provincia de hubei
[Música]
además también se reforzaron los
controles de temperatura que
rutinariamente ya existían volviéndose
por tanto mucho más minuciosos y no sólo
eso también se empezaron a desinfectar
los espacios públicos afectados con
bastante regularidad
vale es verdad todo esto lo hicieron
cuando todavía no había ni un solo caso
de coronavirus en el país como medida
preventiva pero la pregunta más
importante la pregunta que tenemos que
hacernos es qué demonios hicieron cuando
detectaron los primeros casos en corea
del sur- qué estrategia siguió el
gobierno surcoreano es acaso replicable
en otros países pues bien veámoslo el
coronavirus en korea una ardua batalla
amigos cuando ya tienes el coronavirus
en casa hay una cosa imprescindible que
hay que hacer todo lo rápido que sea
posible identificar el origen del
contagio para lograrlo hay que realizar
una investigación hacia atrás para
averiguar dónde estuvo qué contactos
tuvo y cómo se puedo contagiar el primer
paciente
[Música]
pues bien en el caso de corea del sur el
primer caso local se confirmó en la
ciudad de daegu una ciudad de alrededor
de dos millones y medio de habitantes en
el sureste del país
rápidamente en menos de dos días las
autoridades de salud pública surcoreanas
ya habían identificado a la primera
paciente del brote de daegu una mujer
miembro de una secta religiosa lo peor
de todo es que la mujer estuvo en
contacto con al menos 1.000 personas en
dos misas diferentes y así es como se
cree que empezó la propagación del
coronavirus por baidu y aún más poco
después descubrieron que esa misma mujer
había asistido al funeral del hermano
del líder de la secta liman y en el
pueblo de chando y por esos días más
tarde empezaron a aparecer nuevos casos
en ese mismo pueblo
ahora bien tras analizar minuciosamente
el entorno de este caso positivo cual
pensáis que fue el siguiente paso
pues básicamente el gobierno forzó a
esta secta a que le entregasen la lista
completa de miembros era vital aislar lo
antes posible a las personas que
pudieron estar contagiadas y tomar
medidas en las zonas de riesgo una
carrera contrareloj en la que cada
minuto cuenta el caso es que en total
más de 100 mil personas resultaron estar
inscritas en la lista de miembros más de
100.000 personas así que el siguiente
paso que se puso en marcha urgentemente
fue comenzar a realizar pruebas masivas
los más de 100 mil miembros de la secta
empezaron a ser testeados uno por uno
incluso si no presentaban síntomas de
ningún tipo es decir para que nos
entendamos corea del sur comenzó a
realizar pruebas de coronavirus como si
no hubiese mañana uso todos sus
laboratorios disponibles a trabajar de
sol a sol y empezó a desplegar a toda
velocidad una red para hacerse las
pruebas una red muy peculiar
por ejemplo se desarrolló una
curiosísima forma de realizar el proceso
los centros drive thru algo así como ir
al mac auto con tu coche y hacerte una
prueba de coronavirus en poco más de 10
minutos
ahora en el sur está usando drive true
al estilo comida rápida para hacer
pruebas de coronavirus si si lo habéis
escuchado bien impresionante verdad
[Música]
corea del sur ha puesto en marcha
centros en los que llegas en tu propio
coche y sin bajarte del vehículo
abres la ventanilla y te hacen la prueba
de coronavirus luego a las pocas horas
en cuanto están disponibles los
resultados si das positivo te avisan
inmediatamente y te ponen en aislamiento
y tratamiento primero para frenar los
contagios y segundo para empezar la
supervisión del caso lo antes posible y
tratar así de minimizar las
consecuencias nos parece una idea
brillante una idea genial parece casi de
cajón no creéis lo cierto es que no
entiendo como un procedimiento tan claro
aún no se ha copiado en países como por
ejemplo españa
[Música]
en este tipo de casos la previsión y
actuar lo más rápidamente posible es
algo esencial la razón de ser de este
tipo de centros es que el gobierno de
corea del sur entendió desde el primer
minuto que la única manera de ganarle la
carrera al virus era detectando lo antes
de que la gente pudiera multiplicar los
contagios y esto es precisamente lo que
ha hecho que corea del sur sea el país
que más pruebas de coronavirus por
millón de habitantes ha realizado fijaos
[Música]
y lo cierto es que parece que tiene todo
el sentido del mundo a tomar medidas así
cuando hablamos de riesgo epidémico al
fin y al cabo el mayor problema del
coronavirus es que es bastante
contagioso que puede ser portador de
este virus sin mostrar síntomas pudiendo
contagiarse lo a otros lo que puede
provocar que el número de casos crezca
muy rápido y colapse los hospitales y la
infraestructura sanitaria que es
precisamente lo que está ocurriendo en
italia
[Música]
pero para evitar llegar a ese punto otra
de las apuestas del gobierno surcoreano
en esta especie de guerra contra el
coronavirus han sido las aplicaciones
móviles durante esta crisis epidémica en
corea del sur- se han popularizado
aplicaciones que aunque pueda resultar
increíble geolocalizar en los casos de
coronavirus confirmados y dan
información como edad género así como
los lugares que se sabe fueron visitados
por los pacientes crece la popularidad
de las aplicaciones móviles sobre
coronavirus en corea del sur de esa
manera tan solo con usar el móvil los
coreanos pueden evitar acercarse a
potenciales focos de contagio ahora bien
si es verdad que esto puede chocar un
poco con la protección de la privacidad
y eso abre una gran pregunta en casos de
emergencia nacional deben nuestros datos
estar disponibles para su uso a gran
escala debe por ejemplo poder
compartirse en nuestros registros de
geolocalización con este tipo de
aplicaciones aunque sean de forma
anónima son preguntas que os dejamos
abiertas en cualquier caso de lo que no
cabe la menor duda es que entre la
prevención de los contagios y la rapidez
de los diagnósticos korea ha conseguido
un récord que hasta ahora no tiene
competencia en el mundo frenar la
mortalidad del virus
corea del sur atestado a 140.000
personas de coronavirus eso puede
explicar por qué su tasa de letalidad es
de sólo el 0 6% muy inferior a la de
china y eeuu pero esperad un momento
algo me dice que muchos os estaréis
preguntando pero alberto seguro que no
hicieron nada más que eso tan sólo con
esas pocas medidas es como han podido
contener el coronavirus pues bien si
estás en lo cierto no no ha sido lo
único que han hecho hubo muchas más
medidas y entre ellas quizás una la más
básica fue también la más importante
pues imagináis cuál ojo y no me refiero
a garantizar la disponibilidad de
mascarillas lo que evidentemente también
ayuda y en el caso de corea del sur
también han hecho porque el problema de
las mascarillas no es que se utilicen
sino que se utilicen cuando no hay
disponibilidad suficiente para todos
corea del sur- toman nuevas medidas para
tener suficientes mascarillas en el país
en plena crisis de coronavirus
parece que la epidemia tiene
posibilidades de empezar a remitir
nosotros creemos que españa no va a
tener como mucho más allá de algún caso
diagnosticado esperemos que no haya
transmisión local si la hay será
transmisión muy limitada y muy
controlada
el valor de la verdad
os lanzó una pregunta donde pensáis que
está la frontera entre contar la verdad
fomentar el alarmismo y ocultar cosas o
directamente mentir a la gente
ojo porque no es una pregunta nada fácil
de responder para un gobierno cuando le
toca enfrentarse a una situación como
ésta a una crisis de estas
características cuando la situación
amenaza con descontrolarse los gobiernos
tienen que elegir o decir la verdad aún
a riesgo de que la población entre en
pánico y se desate un caos o mentir y
ocultar la realidad dando una sensación
de seguridad que realmente no existe
esta segunda opción es por la que parece
que es apto en españa aunque de eso ya
os hablaremos en un futuro vídeo
mientras que corea del sur se arriesgó y
optó por decir la verdad y ser
transparente fijaos
desde un principio el gobierno se tomó
muy en serio el virus especialmente
porque hace no tanto en 2015 el país fue
sacudido por otro coronavirus el
síndrome respiratorio de oriente medio
commerce s coronavirus es muchísimo más
mortal que el sars coronavirus 2 ya que
tiene una tasa de letalidad del 34 por
ciento o lo que es lo mismo
aproximadamente 10 veces más
es decir en cierto modo esta es una
ventaja con la que ha contado este país
tuvieron una experiencia reciente y
aprendieron de sus errores y aprendieron
que algo fundamental en este tipo de
situaciones era ser transparentes con la
opinión pública y tratar a la gente como
adultos gestionen la verdad y ser claros
[Música]
fijaos de los casi 8.000 casos
registrados en el momento de realizar
este vídeo casi 5.800 están en daegu
es decir tres semanas después el 75% de
los casos siguen estando contenidos en
la ciudad con más transmisiones
comunitarias de toda corea
en saber un momento acaso no es esto
todo un éxito teniendo en cuenta que nos
ha cerrado la ciudad y puesto en
cuarentena ni cancelados los transportes
ni nada de nada como ha conseguido core
a concentrar los casos en una sola
ciudad sin sitiarla como hizo china con
un hand
pues amigos aquí tiene mucho que ver lo
que estamos diciendo de contar la verdad
[Música]
ser transparente y directo con los
ciudadanos desde el principio hizo que
los surcoreanos fueran conscientes de la
gravedad del virus y de la situación que
se avecina va y claro cuando uno conoce
los peligros sabe mucho mejor cómo
reaccionar a ellos para prevenir
contagiarse
de esta forma los surcoreanos dejaron de
salir de casa salvo que fuera
imprescindible cancelaron su vida social
modificaron sus jornadas laborales
apostaron por el teletrabajo e incluso
en algunos casos se les impuso
excelencias temporales en sus puestos
laborales las calles de corea del sur
sus playas sus parques y jardines todo
absolutamente todo se vacío de la noche
a la mañana la vida la alegría que suele
caracterizar a este país de repente
pareció reducirse a una cuarta parte de
lo normal
[Música]
la pregunta que me hago es de verdad que
no merece la pena pasarlo mal durante
unas semanas y aburrirse en casa si así
se puede vencer a toda una epidemia
amigos podemos decir que corea del sur
ha sido todo un ejemplo en los dos
niveles tanto en la reacción del
gobierno y las autoridades de salud
pública como en la reacción de la
ciudadanía que ha actuado demostrando un
nivel de civismo muy alto ahora bien
llegados a este punto crees que el
modelo surcoreano es aplicable en tu
país para vencer al sars coronavirus 2
piensas que tu país está todavía a
tiempo para aplicar estas medidas como
crees que actuarían tus amigos o tu
familia si tuvieran que hacer tantos
sacrificios pues como siempre nuestras
son las preguntas pero vuestras las
respuestas si os ha gustado este vídeo
darle al botón de like y no olvidéis
suscribiros a visual política y darle al
botón de la campanita un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]